Hey so i just got home and uh i'm in Atlanta just
been delivered a package that package is an ipad
and on that ipad is a script this pillow's doing
what nothing and that script is spider-man 3 so
i'm about to find out what i'm going to be doing
for the next five months i'm not going to tell you
anything about it because i've learned my lesson
but um i'm serious oh [ __ ] I broke this ipad
um okay i'm gonna read this now and i can't
wait and i'll speak to you all soon okay so
we just landed in atlanta and uh
it's time for spider-man 3. let's go!
welcome back everyone it's charlie the spectacular
spoiler man is at it again so this is going to
be my new spider-man 3 video tom holland just
arrived on the set we got benedict cumberbatch dr
strange coming in pretty soon too so we'll
break it all down if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos we have a bunch of big stuff coming
up before the end of the year too bunch of big
marvel bunch of big star wars mandalorian stuff
we'll do a new disney plus giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and let me know
what kind of multiverse easter eggs you want to
see during spider-man 3. so just starting with
the big stuff first recently tom holland posted
videos of himself arriving in atlanta to shoot
spider-man 3 finally he'd been finishing his
work on the uncharted movie also from sony sony
doing both of those movies and if you remember
from spiderman far from home this video of him
trying to spoil the movie using the script
is basically the exact same thing that he did
a couple years ago with the title reveal he was
walking around with the ipad and just flashed to
the screen like oops what i just do there i wanted
to apologize because there's no real revelations
coming out this weekend about spider-man 2 i don't
know much about it i'm a little confused because
i died so i don't really know how it all comes
into play but i do know is i've got the new script
i'm super excited to read it and it's going to be
great so yeah spider-man 2 let's do this nowadays
a lot of the stuff that tom holland spoils is on
purpose as part of sony's marketing department
scripting everything for him behind the scenes
so it's a little less spontaneous it's not quite
as cool as when he's actually spoiling stuff like
here's the part where you talk and then you hold
the tablet up and show them what the title of the
movie is don't worry they'll give us a spider-man
3 title reveal later this year there was a sony
marketing executive saying that they were going
to release a preview by december this video
is actually a much better example of what a
free-flowing tom holland spectacular spoiler
man looks like when he's actually getting
ready to spoil something for real like this
is benedict cumberbatch running interference
in interviews trying to stop him from doing
that um i can't talk about this i can't do it
all those avengers infinity war and avengers end
game videos of them together we'll also remind you
benedict cumberbatch's doctor strange is going
to be the big avengers crossover character in
spider-man 3. the pitch that all the hollywood
trades were reporting was that dr strange would
be taking iron man's place as sort of a mentor
figure to spider-man i'll address all the doctor
strange stuff during the movie later in the
video but number four of course tom holland
just as hyped up about spider-man 3 as you are in
talking about future venom crossover the director
of the uncharted movie that he was just working on
is ruben fleischer the director of the venom movie
andy circus is directing venom 2 i mean
they've already finished filming they're
in post-production right now but he did that for
a couple reasons mostly because when it came time
to roll a camera on venom 2 ruben fleischer
wasn't going to be ready to film the movie
but sony wanted to get started and they still
liked him so the uncharted movie was supposed
to start filming after venom 2 so they just put
him on that and there's a little more humor in
that film he's more of a comedic director andy
circus is a little bit better with motion capture
which is super important for the way that they
film the venom and carnage characters so it was
just a big upgrade to bring andy circus onto
the movie the virus just messed all the movie
schedules up for everyone's movies so that's
why they decided to have tom holland film
uncharted before he filmed spider-man 3. right
now spider-man 3 is still coming out during the
christmas holiday next year they're on the same
turnover schedule as they were on the last two
spider-man movies so just in terms of spotting the
new spider-man suits and things on the set that
they feature in the movie we might get a look
at those later in december or early next year
really anytime that they need to film outdoors
with him in the new costumes that's really when
you find out about that stuff and that's when they
have him go on jimmy kimmel and officially reveal
everything like yeah we know that you all
saw this on set but this is what's going on
oh here we go that's you right now that's matt's
mask mine's the one with the white house oh right
right right right all right here you go so
should go without saying yes spider-man is
probably going to get a couple new suits during
spider-man 3. just like he got the new black
stealth suit from nick fury and then he made the
steve ditko inspired classic spider-man suit for
himself using iron man's fabricator we all saw
all those different suit easter eggs that iron man
had designs for i think the logic there is that
when iron man was designing the stark tech suit
originally for captain america civil war then the
iron spider suit for spider-man homecoming he was
workshopping a ton of different iterations and all
those iterations were just different versions from
the comics obviously we all want to see spider-man
wear a version of the symbiote at some point but
i believe that they're saving that for a big big
venom spider-man crossover all the different suits
that they showed during this montage though are
the comic book iron spider the classic colors the
superior spider-man doctor octopus suit the ends
of the earth spider-man armor the classic spider
armor in the secret war suit not to be confused
with secret wars secret war is a different event
that happened a little bit later marvel just
really liked using the secret wars name because
it was such a popular event number three the big
thing about spider-man 3 that's different in terms
of him getting new spider-man suits and technology
is mostly that he's on the run arguably for the
entire film so logically it just wouldn't make as
much sense for him to have a super flashy fully
loaded version of the suit classic spider-man
never really carried around that much gear on him
beyond the mechanical web shooters and the refill
cartridges in his webbing fluid a lot of you long
time comic book spider-man fans have been calling
for tom holland's mcu spider-man to be doing more
stuff on his own not needing help from iron man or
the other avengers kevin feige and the spider-man
movie producers have been talking about how
spider-man far from home was supposed to be him
quote-unquote graduating to make as many
high school metaphors as possible so to speak
from spider-boy to becoming spider-man even the
costume designer on the movie that designed the
new spider-man suit said that that was what
that was meant to signify him making the suit
doing that big iron man callback easter egg where
he's putting his hands on all that tech is meant
to be him graduating to spider-man so the odds
of his next new spider-man suits in spider-man
3 being way more homemade versions of the suit or
like a thousand percent greater he's on his own
nowhere to run what is he gonna do after the first
few major action scenes with the sinister six
villains in the movie like electro when they shred
his suit number two speaking of big costume easter
eggs since doctor strange is crossing over there's
a big spider-man easter egg from the comics that
i hope they go for just paying off something that
they set up way back during avengers infinity war
when spider-man and iron man boarded ebony maw's
ship to save doctor strange peter's waiting up
trying to figure out what to do next and dr
strange's cloak of levitation shows up with
iron man they talk it out then peter tries to have
a moment with the cloak but it stiffs him and just
takes off like don't leave me hanging bro but in
the comics spider-man did wear a cape once and
they even turned it into a joke during spider-man
into the spider-verse spider-man does not wear a
cape nope and then the cape shows up later in the
spider cave they can totally pay off that avengers
infinity war spider cape joke in spider-man 3
or even doctor strange 2 if spider-man is also
going to have a cameo scene in that movie
briefly then of course number one what is
doctor strange actually going to be doing during
spider-man 3 so if he's supposed to be a mentor to
spider-man on the level of iron man that really
means like two longer scenes early in the movie
and at the end of the movie with him also giving
a little assist during one of the major battles
so doctor strange would have seen mysterio's video
at the end of spider-man far from home the whole
world was meant to see the video so as spider-man
goes on the run the producers were joking that he
literally has nowhere to hide in that sinister six
teaser that i did a couple days ago where would he
actually go to hide the sanctum that's the only
place he'd really be safe so remember that funny
scene in thor ragnarok where they're standing
outside wondering what to do next after they
can't find odin and out of nowhere a portal just
opens below loki snatching him imagine spider-man
getting a version of that early in the movie like
he's running ducks into an alleyway and just as
he's about to get caught doctor strange opens a
portal yoinking him to the sanctum helping him out
you also have to remember the multiverse of it
all scarlet witch in Wandavision has already
thoroughly messed up the multiverse at this
point in marvel phase four we're probably going
to start seeing some spider-man multiverse easter
eggs sort of paying off the setup that they had
for mysterio in spider-man far from home i'm not
expecting a ton of live-action spider-burst stuff
right away i just feel like they want to see
that idea out there so that they can actually
turn it into a movie down the road if they want
to go that far but everyone let me know in the
comments what else do you want to see doctor
strange do during spider-man 3 and when do you
want to see tom holland start spoiling stuff my
video for the mandalorian season 2 episode 1 video
is gonna post on friday they'll be doing weekly
episodes eight episodes total just like season
one after that is when we're getting all the
avengers Wandavision episodes i'll also be doing
videos for that too so make sure you have alerts
enabled for my channel so you see all the videos
but while you wait for everything click here for
that brand new avengers moon night teaser trailer
video that they just released and click here
for my brand new spider-man 3 sinister 6 video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!